it's time for screen junkies boobie
fights oh hey what's going on guys
welcome to the new old movie fights we
are going to have a lot of fun too this
is gonna be a weird one and a fun one
and it might just be educational we have
a super all-star cast here to talk about
movies and debate etc and so on right
here in our squared circle of movie
fighting so without further ado let's
see who's here am i right
first up oh you know this guy from Hot
Tub Time Machine pan game ballers the
office Christmas party and he's the
executive producer of the upcoming mr.
neighbours house welcome back to the
show Rob Corddry thank you how are you
oh I'm great how you feeling you're
ready to fight about movies yeah yeah
sure my best friends oh man here friends
become enemies and then become friends
again will they perhaps not I mean maybe
they'll be torn asunder these
friendships second next up you've seen
them on people of Earth Children's
Hospital and he is the the titular star
of upcoming mr. neighbours house mr.
neighbor himself yeah well I'm gonna
show Brian Huskey thanks guys thanks
guys it's great to have you yes there's
some scribble scrambles good job and
last but not least II know I'm from
HBO's loved veep Bob's Burgers welcome
Seth Morris look at that smile
million-dollar smile thank you thank you
thank you how do you really do
absolutely and I like to point out I do
a comedy and stuff at UCB and you guys
all were on an improv group together
back in the day called naked babies at
UCB New York right it's true very cool
guys if you go to YouTube you probably
dig up some some yeah
safe to say we invented sketch the first
ones to do it
yeah the first ones to ever tell a joke
and today deciding these heated movie
debates we have judges first up now a
fact-checker
extraordinaire lon Harris law what's
gonna make that check our guest today
did invent sketch comedy so
congratulations
nice work laptop manly and as always she
is a delight the voice of the people who
will be voicing her own opinions today
not the people's gifts and memes etc
Danielle Radford it's so scary I don't
like having my own opinion I like being
a cypher I love your opinions though
that's very sweet
yeah maybe you should do this but the
people handle it your lack of confidence
is noted yeah and also fair
nailing it
Danielle you got one speed rising to the
occasion so before we get started we
want to know a little bit more about mr.
neighbor's house and I know that you
guys brought a clip but if you want to
kind of summer let us know what it's
about well since is the second one we're
calling it mr. neighbor's house too why
well we wanted to call it mr. neighbor's
house that's a question like the title
twice so are you really in great new
people mine right but you know HR and
you know yeah or or mr. neighbor's house
three and but this because the second
one didn't happen yet right or something
like that yeah but we remember mr.
neighbor's house these are all on the
tax and you were telling me that you
arranged with the producers of the mr.
Rogers documentary for this to come out
very close to the site I asked them to
hold on the release of their movie as
Tom Hanks to hold off on the release of
his movie yes please mr. Rogers mm-hmm
I asked Jim Carrey to create a TV show
that's very similar to our idea and they
all kowtow to you're not Thanos like
demands you you're more relevant than
ever I know right I I am I am the
zeitgeist you are I'm the zeitgeist guys
but basically you're like a weird
twisted Mister Rogers I don't want to
simplify is it say the big picture is
like it's a children's show that may or
may not take place in someone's mind
gotcha and then just go from there guys
so awesome well we have clips from it so
yeah let's take a peek at mr. neighbor
so let me emphasize oh yes also a comedy
you will not be able to tell that from
this trailer what are you thinking
should I open it yeah you have to tell
the truth to enter the door what does
that mean
[Music]
hello friends mister neighbor's house to
premieres June 24th at midnight there
you go
coming up on Adult Swim and when does it
premiere it is June 24th at midnight
Sunday June 24th at midnight now don't
get all in a kerfuffle I know I know we
had we had to fight for using an
ampersand at midnight right with a big
fee for that so it's a Kris hard work
because he owns ampersands now right oh
yeah that was part of his deal look a
little bit like a drug trip is this show
uh it would it be good for druggie so if
I'm a druggie why I enjoy it okay I'm a
druggie yeah and that appealed to me
yeah yeah if you just just think in
terms of like I'm watching Adult Swim
yes I am a druggie or or I sell drugs to
druggies yeah this is the kind of show
where I'm a pharmacist who's given up
yeah getting high on my own supply or
just a normal person yeah - yeah yeah
the whole drug thing but it is not for
children oh yeah no but it's it's
frickin hilarious
and that's up to you later kids yes yeah
I mean to be formative there's some kid
some kid whose five year old it is your
kids up no matter what you might as well
know how you're doing it and yeah choose
this all right that's the thing we can
so great I want to take the heat if your
kid gets Cruz up you know in whatever
just show it and then you can do
whatever you want with your kid but just
always point back to those yeah just
show it to your kid and then tweet at
Brian Huskey
yeah thanks for the damage but yeah the
show is crazy good times and yeah
excited for number two which is also a
name for yes yes joke yeah all right
well I'm also excited to have you guys
here so let's break down the rules one
more time so we have seven questions
three players ship oh yeah
yeah all right so it's a best-of-seven
game we have three regular round
questions which will be decided by the
judges and then the top two scorers
after those three questions we'll go to
the speed round and it doesn't matter if
it's three nothing or whatever the score
is in the speed round it will be decided
there are four questions and the first
player to achieve four points walks out
of here a winner the other two thumb in
a ride home what do we win
hello handshakes and admiration oh wow
okay yeah handshakes yes plural better
than one yeah Oh something else oh yeah
no not hand jobs okay well what do you
say we start this movie fight jte roll
that sick ass package ladies and gents
Thank You JT as always you have the best
package in the biz that's all when one
movie oh yeah that was all from one
movie I'm gonna do well epic epic movie
alright here is the first question in
honor of mr. neighbours house
what movie character would make the
worst children's show host in honor of
mr. neighbours house what movie
character would be the worst children's
show host and we're going to start off
with player number one right here Rob
Corddry that's right
I chose Han Solo what of all the Star
Wars movies except for a couple really
because Han Solo is proudly a smuggler
he's a smuggler on the inside and on the
outside he doesn't i-i've never seen him
with kids so I imagine doesn't care for
them he doesn't even care for the woman
he's he's in love with he would be if
you were a network exec the last person
you would choose to host a children's
show okay was an intergalactic criminal
and yet he has a strong bond with
Chewbacca who is he what if he was a
children's show host would be the
perfect that's a great I got a second
all right
from the operating standpoint he's the
perfect person we will get deeper into
I'll step in here yeah we will get
deeper into that shortly brings up a
good point but Rob is arguing on behalf
of Han Solo and tusky I'm so sorry I
screamed Oh screaming at the top of my
lungs that's okay you got like unusually
angry they're like dare I say irate so I
know I know what we're in store for I
know what we're in store for
Bryan please I only got one more point
to add if I have time oh yeah what's
that come back to everybody oh go ahead
what's his name Bryan okay I have chosen
the character lieutenant from the film
Bad Lieutenant
starring Harvey Keitel gotcha and now if
we remember this gentleman he had a
severe drug problem he had a sex
addiction he was
naked in a church screaming and crying
he abused women he abused his position
as a cop who is a protector of other
people he betrayed all philosophies that
are intrinsic to being a figurehead in
society so for him to speak to children
and sort of give them an example and
teach them would be devastating all
right Harvey Keitel from the Bad
Lieutenant
the lieutenant Seth Morris who do you
got I'm gonna go with Jordan Belfort
from wolf of wallstreet as portrayed by
Lonardo DiCaprio this I I feel like I
shouldn't have to say anymore this is a
despicable person a ruthless capitalists
a quaalude addict and a terrible boat
driver if you remember mm-hmm that is
true
I was got some miglin okay woman and
let's bet he couldn't get it up with
with Margot Robbie more support yeah
because I want to hear you want
something to look up do you wanna know
someone that couldn't really yeah hoist
the mainsail
all right gentlemen fight it out with
these three questionable characters okay
well both you guys are nothing nothing
to do Rob and Seth not even their
character you guys individual ski makes
a good point
husky does make a good joint well I have
made my case with with with you I think
the Han Solo has redeeming qualities
that can be yes that can be sort of
brought out by those who wonder his
redeeming qualities he is faithful he is
loyal he's a rebel no why would he if he
was a rebel he would a cut and run he's
a rebel at heart in the first one he
would never have shown up again he
wouldn't keep coming back for Leia
he wouldn't I don't know sound argument
you don't want your child to be a cookie
cutter you want these people that are
there talking surely be cookie cutter at
Amiens you want somebody who plays by
their own rules a Pied Piper so you want
like che guevara hosting a children's
show
maybe yes yes sir they don't have
t-shirts of Ben Guevarra
right you've never heard of him I stand
corrected right yeah and Han Solo like I
said before from a marketing standpoint
he's perfect for this he also turned his
son into Darth Vader - right mm-hmm
and and that's one of the most popular
characters all right so so in reality in
reality we're talking about a smuggler
who's proud of being a smuggler a
businessman a pinnacle of the business
community who doesn't want his business
to fail and a lieutenant in the New York
Police Department who do you think would
work harder if they hosted a children's
show - to wipe their image clean they
would use this both of these guys would
use this platform as a place to project
the image of being this amazing member
of the community so that they could you
know sell more penny stocks and show
their cars are in the right choice no no
I take the wrong choice no I'm saying
because we're assuming that it's the
worst purse so were you saying that they
were going to clean up their image if
they became children so I'm saying if I
was a network exec I would not I would
choose it would be between you guys so
you say no better show would be these
pinnacles of their fields whereas the
because because they all live there
there shady life in secret nice hi hon
suppose is right on the outside let me
just back up it why you keep saying gram
the Kessel run if you were in a 20 a
part of not that many boats so not too
many parts all parsecs yes parson it was
than anyone took just steam those up
he's wanting galaxies how many galaxies
it sounds Helen wants a new one no - how
many galaxies is the other - wanted in
run that little one again I don't think
I your your case that these guys would
expunge their image to have this
opportunity a kids show
not expunged just keep it Brian can I
put you on the spot
for a moment could you just give me a
taste maybe an impression because I know
you are a practitioner of the comedic
arts oh yeah I do I do a lot I know
impressions are your bailiwick can you
do an impression of Harvey Keitel's Bad
Lieutenant as a children's show host
yeah he comes out naked
yes gives a naked and sort of without
explanation very sweaty and you just
kind of comes out and you just would
sort of stare at the camera and then you
just slowly you get an erection and then
somehow they have to cut away to
something can I do mind when I wander
into my impression of Bad Lieutenant
as children shows he just comes on
spotlight and he's naked and he just
goes do you remember that part does
heroine with that lady in the in the in
their apartment yeah and you can have a
doll squeeze them there is marketing
potential
yeah a lot of marketing but by the way
you said you said worst one right you
know Han Solo that he's he's a smuggler
and a ruthless capitalists on the
outside there's there's a little
somebody else called Joseph Kennedy who
was also both of those things and he
gave us some of the greatest Americans
time we're gonna call now Oh got a joke
Amity yeah we've got we've got a Joe
Kennedy uh you always always put on the
vanity
they came from somewhere all right come
on I know you were feverishly checking
the facts on this round but if you
support or deny the Joe Kennedy great
American can I skip that one up to you
and what else do we hear are is there
such a thing as a Ben Guevara t-shirt
there is no there is a guy a
bodybuilding expert named Ben Guevarra I
did fine we didn't listen today I did
not a ton of facts to check a lot of
ideas thrown back and forth all those
things that we heard about Harvey Keitel
in the bed lieutenant he does do all of
those things those were all true Captain
Kangaroo was surprisingly virile so I'm
glad we covered that and Seth and Rob
the only we were discussing do you have
to be virile or is it a to be a
children's show everything is on Google
yes Google any but did you find nude
pictures of Captain Kangaroo on the dark
web that you didn't check mentioned that
Han is the father of Darth Vader to
Darth Vader to known as Kyle no there's
Tyler Eddy well that well that right so
oh wait you know so like an arsenal um I
got to give you all three of you props
for your arguments they were all very
scholarly mmm not fact riddled and not
Factory yeah we yeah no you you each
made a strong case for who could be who
would be a terrible children's show host
but you know I think Brian really just
stepped into the void and filled it up I
said it's a you know really fun
Harvey Keitel impression mr. neighbor
wanna does he notice a stone you know
unfortunately you your great harvey
keitel impression also helped his case
brian point yeah both amazing harvey
keitel impressions i wish we had more of
those on the show really really well
argued by all of you but i do have to
say I was very taken by one particular
thing that Rob said when he mentioned
that everyone else does their dirt kind
of in secret whereas Han Solo's is out
in the open and for me and we don't have
to fact-check this but I'm sure there
have been plenty of children times to
have done their dirt and secret and that
happens but you don't really get to stay
a kids host of all of your stuff is out
in the open so I'm gonna go with Rob hmm
all right soldiers you're locked up at
one one lon Harris it goes to you to be
a tiebreaker you know I thought that
both Rob and Brian made really strong
cases I thought everybody made did a
good job but as well and I thought Brian
made an excellent point which is you
know Han Solo he is faithful he is loyal
these are great messages to teach the
kids he keeps coming back and helping
his friends in future editions of those
movies so I think that tips it to Brian
oh alright Husky you take the whole line
yourself what round one goes to Brian I
see another $5 bill come later alright
let's go to question number two hey guys
The Incredibles are back Incredibles 2
opens this weekend oh I wish we had all
cliffs on deck but here's the question
what movie family should also get
superpowers what famous movie family
should get superpowers question number
two we'll start with the man in the
number two position here Brian Huskey
okay mainly because I won the first
round I get it that does not bear yes
but I totally know what you didn't say I
bet you're saying okay my my vote was
with the Von Trapp family from The Sound
of Music
mainly because I mean it's wartime
they're Nazis they are in a privileged
environment where they are just being
protected and taken care of by this
nanny why not give them the power to to
contribute and help society at when they
most need it I mean when they need to
superhero I'd say world war two is the
time to do it so and be great and
there's so many of them to do all right
the hills are alive with the sound of
the Von Trapps powers thank you Brian
Seth thanks the Royal tan bumps yeah
they've got the look they've got can you
imagine what anything cooler than a Wes
Anderson designed superhero family and
let's let's be honest all at its root
The Incredibles is about it's about a
family center or family there's emotions
relationships nothing has that more than
the Royal Tenenbaums
let's see that played out with some
action we could have the the Luke Wilson
character his superpower could be
throwing atomic tennis balls of people
and then he's able to kill himself over
and over again and they come back to
life whoa that's like was he not
suicidal in that film yeah that's like
Deadpool playing tennis yeah something
like that one of the Paltrow's character
she could take her her severed finger
throw it like a boomerang knock people
over Ben Stiller just bugs B annoys
people he winds behind them as they're
trying to walk to their cab or whatever
all right hey watch it there kid yeah I
like it Seth breaking down some of the
specific powers the Royal Tenenbaums
let's come right around to rob who do
you got the Corleone
oh yeah no it's it sounds controversial
the head of the five families right
however they are the most sensible
family they are the ones that did not
did not want to do drugs
did not want to start selling drugs did
not get in with Bruno Tattaglia because
they are the ones who always want to get
out they want to get out of crime
imagine if they had superpowers how
easily it would have been for them to
get out of the crime business they
wouldn't even have been a godfather
three we wouldn't even had to worry
about it then are you an argument if
there wasn't Godfather three yeah be
choose how would the world keeps
spinning right now I do
all right gentlemen fight it out okay
well I'm just gonna respond to throw up
saying so your point is because they are
criminals who want to get out of being
criminals yes they should be superheroes
they're smart and they want to get out
yes
okay so they have an inherent lust for
money
no and power not necessarily yeah okay
well they have that by default go on by
default what does that mean that's like
Vito Corleone only wanted to support his
family all he wanted to do was feed his
family
mm-hmm and he got a rug from what's his
bruno kirby he got a rug as a gift and
then next thing you know he found
himself the smartest person in a crime
family but I think for the sake of this
argument you have to choose which
definitive family at which time you
can't go all the way back into the pre
the prequel history of like vo Corleone
II are we talking about yeah one - I've
said the Corleone family it's like
starting with Vito and then leading all
the way up until well hopefully not Andy
Garcia because I wouldn't want him to
have superpowers I I leave that's an
addendum to my argument okay I think I
think your argument is a little too
broad in that you're saying like yes
everybody in his family the hole is so
broad that crime maybe we will solve
crime in the United
I'm saying that she had superpowers
they'd be they be crime fighters I would
say yeah who would you want who would
you want fighting crime somebody who
doesn't really know what criminals how
criminals fight or Mike someone as smart
as Michael Corleone who has been there
who just wants to get and what do you do
about the loose cannon of yeah so guys
James Caan in the Andy Garcia yeah maybe
that would have been so vented and also
a bad a horrible murder might have been
prevented at the those Long Island toll
booths yeah I think I think your
argument is based on rewriting the
entire history of the godmother family
which would not exist there you could
not choose that family the Von Trapp
family are Nazi sympathizers right deny
it did I read that movie right there
like they're dating Nazis they're gonna
join the nutso youth some of the kids so
you're giving superpowers to the image
which person is your name Rolf I don't
know I was watching with half an eye
like oh you Von Trapps you love us
something like that that's an example I
would love to hear a little bit more
about some of the specific superpowers
sets start laying out like how those
powers are translate in application yeah
you know to do that you would probably
have to be aware of the specifics of the
movie or the character I'm not prepared
to do that right I'm you know I'm not
into specifics I'm about do it even bro
the Von Trapp family von Trapp family oh
okay I think the big picture like that
as a superhero but they were to sing
better they all can sing great I think
their superpower they all sort of morph
together into one super being like a
Voltron type yeah Voltron little kids
and then they could be sent in like a
giant creature made out of children
I attract of superheroes that's crazy
that would be a giant Aryan monster yeah
that would be Hitler's wet dream a fan
even if you guys are arguing the point
that they work they work within the Nazi
Party what better way to bring it down
than from working with they're gonna be
so conspicuous they're a giant like what
are they could you just my argument
about Corleone's know what what is what
would be a couple of uh what would be a
couple of the Corleone family powers
Michael of course would have the power
of persuasion more than he already does
he's a very persuasive person he'd have
the power of persuasion like he would
magically persuade anybody to do what he
wanted it'd be a bit real hypnosis not
that mumbo-jumbo and Fredo would have
the superpower of just just laying low
turning in the family like the boat the
superpower of an impulse and actual
control on his impulse what would the
actual Godfather's power be Oh Vito
Corleone yeah yeah
oh my gosh well so he would that was
walking about I was talking about the
Depression era previous to the
Depression era he would be a hero to
immigrants and I feel like your
immigrant superpowers to just be to have
the bare minimum of decency to not be
may don't wanna be in crime the time Wow
they don't want what epic battle I could
snow I used to get to the neurotic rich
people well I would like to see a battle
royale of all three of these families
with their super powers powerful
arguments lon any facts to be checked we
should say the Von Trapp family not
usually thought of as Nazi sympathizers
actually sled news did not want to serve
in the German Navy due to his opposition
to the Nazis that's why the family fled
to Italy and later the United States do
you want to get that out of there bruno
kirby he plays Peter Clemenza in the
Godfather films and Andy Garcia plays
Vincent Corleone those are all right
thank you for that guy was actually in
Godfather in the first Godfather he's
the big fat one comment fact Lomenzo
young he's the young version about okay
okay hey Danielle where do you stand on
this argument this is just really really
fantastic arguments um as much as I
appreciate that the Corleone's would
want to get out of that they want to get
out of crime I don't know that's a
strong enough reason to keep some with
superpowers
thank you do you think it's really good
with with the Von Trapps as I do like
the idea of the morphing into as someone
else right you got as I do it there you
had come up with more specific powers
and so I've got to go with the Royal
Tenenbaums yeah something we know that
some things would look good if it was
kind of Wes Anderson ish cuz Legion is
amazing I said it oh god they're gonna
at me okay I did to myself I really like
the very specific powers on each of them
um and especially you hittin with not
only you hit it on why it's important
they're family and how the movies are so
much about family and how family deals
with things and goes through things yeah
you do think you're gonna cry at the
incredibles - you're lying
that's one point for none of you none of
you chose my favorite movie family which
has been Diesel's family and fastened
the Furious oh yeah they're survivors in
Clown Posse
Juggalos our family yeah so yeah I agree
with much of what Danielle said Rob and
when you were listing the super powers
they were not super powers they were the
simple character traits already has
super soft but I love yours Brian I was
like the catchphrase the the hills are
alive with the sound of a horrific child
monster yeah for the exact same reasons
Danielle laid out I thought Seth had
just a excellent opening argument and
yeah I'm picturing all those different
tenants coming together I their weird
powers you see only when you guys showed
the the still from the promotional still
there yeah once we saw that you know we
wasted seven minutes after this game set
match Martha said you get the point
you're tied 1-1 going into question
number three wow this is a great moment
in sports all right
here is question number three what's the
most unfairly underrated movie of all
time
Wow quite a question we're gonna settle
it today
and we're gonna start with player number
three Seth all right this one this one
is this is serious I've been joking
around before
dead serious thunderbolt and Lightfoot I
don't know the year we can fact check it
74 is it it's a young Jeff Bridges and a
slightly older than young Clint Eastwood
it's a heist movie it's a robbery movie
it's an a road movie it's incredible
it's one of those movies where you see
it's like watching mean streets where
you see Harvey Keitel and Robert De Niro
like they were that good right away same
thing with Jeff Bridges so incredible
right away not to give too much away but
he does the last quarter of the of the
movie with a brain injury and it's
incredible heartbreaking acting Clint
Eastwood is a badass it's fantastic and
it's not one of those status it's not
one of those movies from the 70s that
you're like oh that's cool I'll watch
the Steve McQueen movie and it's boring
boring boring and then there's a chase
scene at the end yeah this is an
action-packed movie from the get all
right Seth Morris thunderbolt and
Lightfoot and found out he hates Steve
McQueen
back around to rob my the movie I chose
was fire walk with me like David Lynch
now you could pretty much argue that any
David Lynch movie is fantastic this
movie however even though it's it's an
amazing movie got booed like people
French people stood up there I'm so
disappointed in David Wright and David
however over over time people have at
least said maybe we were wrong maybe
maybe we were wrong about that and so it
it is it's hard to quantify like qualify
each David Lynch movie like which is the
best but I would say it's it's in the
top five David Lynch movies and and
deserves way more appreciation all right
2010 wire walk with me
we'll hear more about it Bryan yeah
what's your choice oh I'm gonna choose
Logan you know Wolverine dude it is the
story of the thing I love about this
movie was I went in with low
expectations because at this point
they're just cranking out you know the
Marvel Universe in a tentpole fashion
what I think is excellent about this
film is it is as true to a graphic novel
in tone and execution as you can
probably get it really it really
investigates the the dilemma of the
antihero it takes so many it takes all
these heroes and reduces them to nothing
where they have to face their own sort
of their own mortality their own
vulnerabilities as he has his
relationship with his daughter and it is
it's not you know good versus evil it's
self versus self and evil is sort of
instigating that and I was really I
loved it I didn't think I'd like it and
I was like I think a powerful summation
of Logan from Brian Huskey all right
fellas fight it out what's his name in
Lightfoot was a
movie however in terms of no no it's not
ways in life but like Brian asked me
yeah Thunder Thunder face and Lightfoot
Thunder feet thunderbolt life euzeth
with ten-speed brown shoe the Ben Vereen
Jeff Goldblum show which was fairly
under appreciate it was love yes where
is he not a mirror I would say that that
movie is while I have never seen it
while it sounds great it and it's got
all the checks all the boxes it never
rose up there's so many movies in the
70s and the middle 70s my point
nope that that were so good that the bar
was higher for movies in the 70s and I
think it's probably earned its value and
appreciation it's probably appreciated
just as much as it should be pal Mary
but absolutely oh you're talking about
underrated movies the fact you haven't
seen it proves my point the fact that
it's it's an acknowledged great movie
from the 70s but most people don't know
it proves my point there's too many
movies to see we still that's on you
I'm too busy watching that movie stupid
they're both is both of these guys make
great points but waiting me don't you
what's this a finger Derek touch me hey
got time you point a finger at him you
got three points well again first of all
the Sun was not an underappreciated
movie yeah it was yeah
well appreciate it as well appreciate
you love that movie yeah but not many
people as a lot of people have not seen
it like it is not as appreciated as they
make it seeing it doesn't make me this
topic we're debating is under rated and
is rated high yes I'm a box-office here
yeah no no guys wake up to the new
reality
brother brother
yeah it was a it was probably if you
asked anybody on the street and give
them a choice of x-men movies which
one's the best that would probably nine
times out of ten be the one I'll think
the guy the guy with his hat they were
slightly sideways and the board choice
it's gonna choose this one he's gonna go
with the one he's just gonna say x-men
doesn't count
yeah yeah no I mean that's the things
like there are movies to your point
there are movies that are critical
you know critically acclaimed and you
know beloved and they do well the box
office but then they don't they don't
stand that they don't sort of take their
position in you know in the Canon and I
think this is one that should take it's
because I think it has I think you know
I would argue for yours
which one was drafted by David Lynch is
that and reserves more appreciated and
underrated David Lynch movie but it's
it's a lot of people know and love that
movie because everything he does is
called the people that like him love
everything he does the people that like
him sure but I think we're talking about
broad terms right like my my father
being like what why hasn't he watched
either of these movies he hasn't seen
this movie because people booted it Khan
I you know I love Inland Empire that's
what I watch that was the Palm D'Or this
but if we're talking about that like
this sort of like you know not the
devotee of film and stuff they're not
gonna they're not gonna gravitate
towards like a film like that or even
Logan they'll be like Alan I was like a
superior underappreciated it's like so
it's a also it has characters from a TV
show in it which makes it in it more
inaccessible to even David Lynch fans
supposedly however if you watch that
movie it has you can it stands alone as
a great movie
not standalone you don't have to know
anything about the it's it's like it's
like a luxurious bibliography to
something that came before it's out of
context it doesn't it doesn't stick it's
not as strong yeah you're not gonna get
as much out of it if you didn't watch
trim I have a blue rose tattoo time Wow
I don't know what that means it was a
close-up and I can tell you a good shot
of the blue rose all right Wow quite a
throw down here lawn facts so man when a
thunderbolt Lightfoot commander boldly
did come out in 1974 well done got that
nailed that one interesting side that
thanks Peter brown shoe a detective
series that lasted for one season on ABC
was the first show to come from Stephen
Jay Canal productions one year before
Greatest American Hero one thing I do
have to mention there is a lot of debate
still about whether or not fire walk
with me was actually booed at Conn there
were initial media reports even believe
it now
the film's co-writer Robert angle says
he attended the premiere and people did
not buoys and the audience kind of
didn't know what to make of it but
they're not booing just been saying it
is an ongoing back and forth of debates
what I would say - if my
underappreciated movie you know was all
right lon thank you for that oh uh you
know what Brian what's up I think you
were correct in your love of Logan but I
think these fellows were correct in
pointing out that Logan is a well-loved
appreciated movie I mean and I look
forward to you approaching a gentleman
with a sideways hat and board shorts
yeah getting his opinion I gotta find a
guy who's this for this one I feel like
they they knocked it down with that with
those points and translation get in the
toilet
so for me it came down to Robinson I
thought these were both great choices
but Robin I felt like they took the piss
out of your vinegar at the end of there
at the end when they called out I have
that land Rose Tattoo shrew true again
Seth you came in again with the great
opening salvo and then I thought you had
some good rebuttals for your movie as
they tried to cast aspersions on it so I
got to go thunderbolt and Lightfoot Seth
Morris and so it could be garbage it's a
real thank you
let's go to Danielle Radford oh man you
didn't this is another great fight
really good arguments I do maybe it's
because I work in this space people
definitely appreciate Logan but I do
really appreciate that argument those
are very good I that the the debate
about whether or not you need to have
seen Twin Peaks before seeing fire walk
with me was one that was really really
interesting and when you mentioned that
it seemed like it was inaccessible but
it is something that stood alone I
thought that was a great argument for me
but I've got a I got agree with how I
got to go with thunderbolt and Lightfoot
sorry you seemed like you were going
with him even you seem like she's fly no
but she seems like she was you see a
path
to these judges but I chose the best
movie that's the takeaway one that means
it's time for the speed round here is
how the speed round boy works ok so
cooking yes
snort your cocaine and get ready for the
speed round I will throw out the
question the first person to answer will
get to elaborate on their answer first
and so you will each get 20 seconds and
20 seconds and then 10 second rebuttal
10 second rebuttal and again I'll ask
the question shout out your answers once
we have both answers then we will hear
from the person who spoke first okay
score currently stands at 2 1 Seth and
maybe we'll go Rob you want to chime in
as a judge this round yeah I'll go back
and forth between you guys or myself Rob
you'll get to chime in as a judge so you
won't have to sit there mum ah hard
shell all right fellas you ready yeah
let's do this ok here's the first
question of the speed round
what active 2018 franchise should just
give it a rest already predator or
Jurassic Park dress bar president Park
from 7 we heard we got predator from
Brian Huskey alright 20 seconds begin
when you start speaking okay I just
wanted to give myself a lead in there
Jurassic Park it's it's imperative part
in our culture where we are doing an
embarrassing embarrassing amount of
reboots of remounts this was a beautiful
franchise let it rest we don't need this
to turn into another what dare I say
Star Wars which is which is becoming
we're over saturating first area time
okay 20 seconds begin when you speak the
irony is I watched Jurassic world last
night and I actually loved it I had
watched the two and three from the first
you know version and they were terrible
and I thought this was a great solution
and sort of like investigation of where
this should go because the if the theme
is a
corruption of money and the idea of
control of nature they did it okay
reboot 10 second rebuttal predator is a
much cooler franchise to follow because
it unlike Jurassic Park it hasn't been
explored in the depths that Jurassic
Park has which is essentially doing the
same movie over and over again
yeah but predator I would say is sort of
limitations are the characters it's just
about these two hunting the uber beings
and Jurassic series is more about human
being it's about two people I am Wow
alright some good points on both sides
Rob Corddry once you weigh in with a pic
I really wanted to go with Seth on this
one
however husky made his point right off
the bat like Jurassic Jurassic Park is
pretty good I wouldn't mind seeing
another installment of that because
there's so many and he also made at the
very end there's so many more
possibilities there's so many places to
go whereas after a world what at
Jurassic universe they get out into
space
hi the universe is the limit yeah
fighting Jason and space all right
that's one for husky Daniel Radford Oh
still very good arguments I am going
with Seth because as much as great as
the arguments of Brian had were there
was more I didn't hear enough about
predator in this it was very much an
argument that was solely based on
Jurassic world and so since I didn't get
a lot of that really good predator stuff
I I got to go with 7 ok it's 1:1 let's
go to lone Harris Wow yeah I think both
made a compelling case and these are
both branches as I could see sort of
hitting the pause button on but
ultimately yeah I think I got a go set
that I like his argument that we've sort
of seen them do the theme park a bunch
of times but there's more to explore in
the predator premise that we haven't
done yet so that's where I'm going
all right Seth takes that point it is
3:1 Seth Morris this gentleman is my
endpoint if Seth takes this game over
man game over if I win this one you know
like that doesn't work like that you are
locked in this Jamison's great question
number two okay
root from the headlines The Hulk Hogan
versus Gawker case will be turned into a
movie who should play ho Hogan ok we
have the rock who's the guy that James
Franco was based on in Spring Breakers
Oh high roller yes
riff-raff slash Jody high roller okay so
we got riff raff the grilled braided
rapper portrayed by now buff I will add
oh yeah Johnny bob become a wrestler
versus the rock
Brian you spoke first 20 seconds again
whenever you speak now my choice was
based on the fact that he was stammering
and that's the first thing I thought
Mike Reid is always the first thought is
the best thought not true but it's a
sort of a life lesson so if I can if I
lose a point that's fine but if I can
teach anybody anything first thought is
always the best one not true Wow Wow
sacrificing his opening argument Seth
okay
riff-raff is training but he's beat
training to be a pro wrestler a
bodybuilder being trained by Hulk Hogan
he's studying this man hour by hour day
by day he
yes what is gonna be more interesting
the rock doing something you know he's
probably gonna do a fine job or the the
anticipation the thrill ride of seeing
what time okay ten seconds you know I
guess in the big picture like this want
to take stock of like the moments to
mean something and whether time runs out
or not it's hot all right you got a row
but that it so Marcus if you haven't
seen riffraff on hot ones do it right
now it's it's amazing like you want to
see that guy carry a film for two hours
I'll eat the rest of my alright lassie
no no supportive very mundane anything
you've said unlike mine okay man what a
battle right there Rob give us some
sauce confusing
first of all hearing the two choices I
wanted to go with husky only because I'm
contractually obligated to the rock star
ballers HBO's ball because he's my best
friend
yes call him right now see if he takes
your call and and first I was so against
Seth because I was like this guy bit
this kid guide lose a fish kennel
character is based on him is gonna play
a real it was very confusing to me but
boy you really laid out on argument
right you you know really is do you know
about you no idea but I'm convinced
anyway oh yeah yeah
I started trained by Hokage that sealed
the deal right there yeah Huskies though
point about time was that point right
yeah I mean did about something yeah all
right so that's one for Seth and
so he's close right um you know what I
learned a valuable lesson and that's
worth you know all the points in the
world but I give my point to Seth as
well I did not know that that was
happening with riffraff it's true you
earn that and you earn the movie fights
victory today congratulations
yeah tell us how what you're up to plug
some stuff and I'm just gonna plug I'm
gonna plug mr. neighbor's house which
sounds anju I'm in a plug
Seth is Morris at I don't use Twitter or
more it's a cesspool Instagram and and
that's it
hell yeah Seth Morris thank you very
much sir well fought ah Brian Huskey
the titular mr. neighbor please tell us
again when and where we can find it
here's the lowdown yeah it is June 24th
Sunday June 24th at midnight on Adult
Swim
set your DVRs for two nights in a row
because it will screw them up not know
how to handle their DVR another backup
backup DVR and you can find me on
Twitter and on Instagram at V Brian
Huskey awesome well-fought great having
you today and Rob Corddry I apologize I
never asked you to go to Harvey Keitel
impression so if you would like to give
us your Harvey Keitel impression there's
pretty much one one yeah dude
please I gotta there's this one too in
the movie the car windows yep
and yeah tell us how where we can find
you I I'm gonna plug mister neighbors
hell yeah
this is a really really really good show
I think it's better than the first one
everybody should see it yeah heck yeah
and these are three super funny dudes
and I have no doubt that mr. neighbours
house number two is going to be awesome
lawn Harris hey yeah mr. neighbours
house watch mr. neighbor's house on
Adult Swim it's gonna be hilarious you
guys like comedy this is a funny show
record it on your DBS turn a personality
viewers yes : a Star Wars reduce Daniel
Radford thank you for everything today
please go ahead and say some stuff uh as
per always follow me on Instagram so I
can get more of them fat girl free
clothes at Danielle understood Radford
please I need more dresses with flowers
on them let me get that pleasure and
yeah yeah I follow my wrestling podcast
types and fights yeah things are fun
this was great yeah so much fun again I
want to thank Seth Mars Brian Huskey Rob
Corddry watch mr. neighbor's house too
on Adult Swim on June 24th at midnight
midnight yes on Adult Swim and I want to
thank you for watching movie fights I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye bye
I lost
[Music]
you